you know so in in in some sense there
could be even a hierarchy of virtual
agents I actually quite like that idea
because as soon as there is an outcome
to the meme existing for example the
virtual agent existing there's an
interaction that's occurring that in
itself is that object acting producing
an action and it resulting in a
consequence a observation in the shared
environment of the agents that are
interacting with one another and so
again to bring back the whole like
semantics of language and it it
developing its own identity right um I
think that's the same thing with memes
memes wouldn't exist if we didn't exist
to interpret them right um but they
exist and are passing passing some
information to us and that is the
outcome in itself so it has its meaning
its semantics develops over time so it
does exist